hello everyone and welcome to not one
but two incredible games from the ulio
bar generation Cup first one we are
going to show is Fabiano corana versus
Magnus Carlson and then we are going to
show you what happened in the match ala
fuia versus Wesley so let's dive
straight into it uh like I said both
games are incredible and um I don't want
to spoil anything before we enjoy the
move so H Fabby has the wi pieces and he
opens with C4 and uh I wait till you see
this opening Pawn to G6 by Magnus he
goes for the so-called Great Snake
variation against the English we have
Pawn to E4 and now Knight to F6 and uh
incredible as it is already as of move
two we have a completely new game uh
that's when we're talking about
classical games of course there are some
games that reach this um position that
were played online uh but I'm not really
interested in those okay Pawn to E5 uh
in the spirit uh you know how you would
play against let's say the AL in defense
Knight to H5 and now Pawn to D4 and now
look at this Fabby has the beautiful
Center and the Magnus has a knight on H5
because why not but okay we all know
what that means he will try to undermine
fabby's strong Center much like he would
um white strong Center in the Alin
defense so D6 and pawn to F4 uh Bishop
to H6 and this is the position that we
should discuss because already it could
be considered a critical position now
how you should play this and I've
actually allowed the engine to really
crunch the numbers here up to some move
uh depth 45 you should just give up the
pawn you should play Knight to C3 and go
for the initiative and after Bishop
captures on F4 Bishop captures and
Knight captures you just play e captures
and after Queen captures you play Queen
D2 and prepare Queens side castles black
will play Pawn to C6 to stop pawn pawn
to D5 Queens side castles and we have a
castles on opposite sides most likely
black will Castle King's side and then
you will go after the black king so this
is how this should be played and the
engine says yes the pawn sacrifice is
the only way to play this however Fabby
tried to defend it with Pawn to G3 as it
also Al looks very nice but it just
allows Magnus to trade everything off
and go straight into a much better end
game for him so he played de captures on
E5 uh D captures and queen captures on
D1 King captures and now Knight to C6 we
have Bishop to D2 by Fabby and Bishop to
F5 we have Bishop to G2 and now Queen
side castles inviting Fabby to capture
on C6 H but it will also mean that he
will have to give up his Bishop pair so
he just moves the king king D1 you have
to unpin here and now comes Knight to D4
and already you can feel that magnus's
pieces are too deep in Fab's position
Knight to C2 already being the threat so
Knight to A3 and now we have Pawn to F6
challenging white strong Center Knight
to F3 developing and defending and now
Bishop to
E4 and here you would love to Castle but
you can't uh you know it's very easy to
get rid of the Knight and then just pick
up the bishop on D2 so Rook to F1
instead and now Bishop captures on F3 we
have Bishop captures and now f captures
on E5 and this is what um uh we always
say when we mean what when we say that
you have to undermine White Center
because now Fabby cannot capture back uh
the problem is if you capture back it's
the exact same idea Bishop captures on
D2 with check King captures and now a
nice double discovery check knight from
the Knight and from The Rook you lose a
piece and of course the game so Fabby
has to resort to Bishop captures on H5 G
captures and now play Rook to D1 so the
bishop is nicely defended Magnus piles
up on the F Pawn with Rook H to f8 and
now Bishop to C3 and here Magnus goes
for Rook to F5 and Faby has to uh really
figure out how to play this you could
continue with Pawn to B4 as you could in
pretty much any position uh but uh the
the key move is uh F captures on E5 if
you want to blunder the game so this was
not played I'm just going to show you
why it cannot be played and why Fabby
played the move that he did now Rook
captures an E5 check would be played
King F2 rookie to check King to G1 and
now Knight to F3 with check check and
now you're getting checkmated whatever
you play if King to H1 then Rook
captures on H2 is Checkmate and if you
capture of course Rook captures on D1 is
check Rook to F1 and now a very nice
Bishop to E3 check forcing the white
king to step away from The Rook King H1
and Rook captures on F1 will be
Checkmate uh so after Rook F5 uh Fabby
played Rook to F2 he gave the F1 Square
to the king and now uh F captures on E5
is what Fabby wants to play next so
Magnus played Pawn to H4 F captures and
Rook captures on E5 now it's not
Checkmate Faby plays King to F1 uh
Bishop to E3 going after the rook and
The Rook to F7 very very active Rook um
uh on the seventh trank for Fabby but
now H captures on G3 H captures and Rook
to F5 of course Magnus will not allow
this Rook to you know wreak havoc on the
seventh rank so Rook captures Knight
captures and now Rook captures on d8 uh
King captures now King to E2 going after
the bishop but now comes Bishop to D4
and the problem is Magnus won a pawn in
uh all that Madness on the king side and
uh now he's forcing further trades which
will only be better for him the problem
is you cannot play something like G4
because then just Bishop captures on C3
threatening to capture another pawn and
once you capture he will just go back
now you're not just down a pawn you're
down a pawn and have a double C Pawn
which is terrible so instead after
Bishop D4 Fabby has to trade Bishop
captures Knight captures and now King to
E3 and Knight to C6 we have a knight end
game and Magnus is up a pawn and he does
have the past E Pawn so let's see how he
plays this we have Knight to B5 King to
D7 now comes Knight to C3 we have King
to E6 and now Knight to B5 Faby goes
after the pawns here but just King to F5
not even worried about uh defending this
Pawn here as he wants uh to take this
pawn and of course his Knight wants to
grab the pawns on the queen side so Faby
does capture it there's no better move
and now King to G4 we have King to F2
defending the G3 Pawn but now Knight to
B4 threatening the A2 Pawn and if you
play A3 of course Knight to D3 check
will pick up the B2 Pawn so Faby defends
the B Pawn Instead at least it will not
give him more Pawn Island so Knight
captures on A2 and now Knight to D5 goes
after the E7 Pawn but now Pawn to A5 and
uh okay you could go after the E7 Pawn
but then comes Knight the C1 you lose
the B3 pawn and then the a pawn marches
forward and becomes a queen so instead
Knight to E3 check we have King to H3
and now Knight to F1
uh we have Knight to C1 Magnus goes
after the B3 Pawn H Knight to D2 Fabby
defends it we have King to G4 and now
King to G2 and the problem is now the
Knight is St guarding the B3 pawn and
the king is St guarding the G3 pawn and
now uh Fabby can uh cannot move anything
you can't move the Knight and the only
thing you can do with the king is move
it King F1 King G2 King F2 King G2 uh
it's not you know a great way to live
but you know you have no choices here so
H5 now comes King F2 PA Pawn to E5 and
now King to G2 and now even Pawn to E4
of course if you capture the Knight
captures on B3 creates a pass Pawn so
far be forced to repeat but now even
Pawn to E3 with check you don't have to
play this but it's um you know a fine
way to end the game King captures on G3
Knight to E4 check and now King to G2
now comes King to D2 attacking the
Knight but now Knight captures on B3
check we have King to C3 attacking the
Knight but here Magnus just played Pawn
to H4 and he was in this position on
move 46 that Fabiano corana resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here uh the problem is once you go let's
say Knight G5 to sacrifice the Knight
for the
pawn of course Magnus will not allow
that he will play Knight to C5 and after
King to D4 uh attacking the Knight he
will play Pawn to A4 now if you capture
the Knight this Pawn becomes a queen so
King back to C3 but now King to G3 now
you will kick away the Knight and after
King to B4 now you'll just play B6 so
there's really no good move here King C3
now A3 now B3 and B2 are covered by the
Knight and pawn so the King has to go
all the all the way around uh King G4
and after Knight to F7 now we just play
H3 and of course there is no defense
against two connected pass pawn two
connected outside pass Pawns of course
uh Fabby knew this and un move 46 he
resigned and basically uh I mean how do
you play this against a former 2800
players like Fabby look at this position
this was magnus's position and like I
said this was the critical position came
down to this uh when um this bishop to
H6 move was played he attacked the F4
pawn and Fabby thought all right it's I
mean it's a silly move that Magnus is
playing let's just defend it and here I
believe that this was the position where
he just lost the thread of the game and
where Magnus just took over uh but
that's the the first game that we are
going to show from the semi-finals as
Magnus has defeated Fabby and he's in
the finals of the UL B generation cup uh
of the winner section and now we are
going to check out what happened in the
game Wesley saw versus ala fua uh let me
just uh oop sorry not that uh not that
sorry this is uh I have to add the other
one just give me a few seconds or you
can you know uh fast
forward uh where is the one where is the
one there it is H there we go all right
sorry about
that there we go all right now now you
see how it's done so it's ala with the
white pieces Wesley with black and Al
just incredible attack in game you guys
will really enjoy this one it's a really
quick one so let's check it out ala has
plays Pawn to E4 we have Pawn to E5
Knight F3 Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5
so a standard R Lopez nothing
spectacular A6 morphy's defense Bishop
to A4 and now Knight to F6 uh we have
castles and Bishop to E7 uh we have a
pawn to D3 and pawn to B5 again we've
seen this many many times Bishop to B3
D6 and now Pawn to C3 bringing up the C2
Square for the Bishop if needed also
preparing Pawn to D4 uh we have castles
and H3 we have Rook to E8 and now comes
Rook to E1 H6 and now Pawn to A4 so
again all been play before uh we have
Rook to B8 and now a captures on B5 we
have a captures on B5 and now Pawn to D4
striking in the center Bishop to f8 and
now Pawn to D5 grabbing more space in
the center chasing away the Knight we
have Knight to E7 and now Bishop to a e3
and here uh very peculiar move happens
that um you should not play but I guess
Wesley tried it as a as a surprise as
this is rapid time form it Knight
captures on e4 and now okay you can play
it but uh if played well black doesn't
really get all that much Ala plays
Bishop to A7 and it looks like okay what
is this uh you're attacking the rook and
also the Knight on e4 is hanging uh Rook
to A8 and ala grabs the Knight with Rook
captures um on e4 but now comes Bishop
to F5 attacking the rook and and what
would you play here well the problem
with moving The Rook back and saying
okay I'm just up a piece is that you're
not up a piece if Knight to see it your
Bishop is hanging now and if you move it
then The Rook on A1 hangs so you can't
just move the Rook back so instead after
Bishop to F5 Knight to B2 was played
Knight B to D2 uh and uh now just Bishop
captures on e4 okay you win the exchange
Knight captures and now Queen to C8 but
basically you have a rook for two pieces
uh we have Pawn to G4 by Ala we have
Queen to be sorry not there uh Queen to
B7 now preparing to capture the bishop
and now Bishop to E3 by playing this
Knight B to d2 move ala also made sure
that his Queen defends The Rook on A1 so
okay Rook captures on A1 Queen captures
on A1 and now Knight captures on D5 and
now what's the problem with Wesley's
idea uh why doesn't this work well this
is only the first pause the video moment
of the game so feel free to pause the
video and try to find what Wesley missed
while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this
wild idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Bishop
captur on H6 that's the move and it
looks like a really weird move but then
once you see it you cannot unsee it
Bishop captures on H6 was played and of
course Wesley cannot touch the bishop if
he takes the bishop then look at his
Bishop captures on D5 and now you see
what happened if Queen captures Knight
F6 check picks up the queen so of course
after Bishop captures on H6 Wesley has
to play something and the best way to
play this is to ignore the bishop all
together just play C5 uh C4 and okay the
game continues nothing the bishop has to
go back and okay let's say Bishop to D2
C4 Bishop comes to C2 uh you you lost
the H3 Pawn H6 Pawn but the game
continues however after Bishop captures
an H6 Wesley played Knight to F6 and now
alza goes in for the kill Knight
captures we have G captures and now his
position is completely winning but only
if you find one move that is so
ridiculous to find um especially in a
rapid game uh it's uh I mean of course
not for for players of of their strength
but if you found this then I mean truly
you are a an incredible incredible
player so feel free to pause the video
and win the game for ala while I give
you a couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it and I imagine all of you
were able to do it congratulations I
expect no less and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Queen
to B1 that's the idea of course the
bishop controls this diagonal the F7
Pawn basically does not exist so by
playing Queen to B1 you are preparing
Queen to G6 check and there is no way to
stop it as the king cannot go here and
the King cannot go here so Queen to B1
uh absolutely crushing and now if you
even if you capture the bishop doesn't
work because Queen to G6 check and now
if you go Bishop to G7 just Queen
captures an F7 with check and now if
King to h8 of course Queen to H5 check
uh Bishop to H6 and this will now be
Checkmate the bishop covers G8 and if
you don't go to h8 if you go to H7 which
is a little bit better doesn't really
matter still Queen H5 check you have to
block with the bishop now comes Queen to
F5 with check King to G7 and now Queen
to D7 with check again you nicely
connect with the Rook so there was no
way to avoid that king h8 queen captures
King to H7 and queen to G8 will be
Checkmate so doesn't matter what you do
so after Queen B1 wasley said all right
I will just close this diagonal so
nothing really happens here but now Ala
plays Bishop captures on f8 uh King
captures and now Knight to D4 and okay
you survived a little bit but it's still
bishop and Knight versus rook and your
king side is completely messed up uh
Pawn to D5 but now Knight to F5 nicely
controlling these squares and now the
queen is going in for the kill uh we
have Rook to E5 now comes Queen to C1 so
imagine this uh this attack I mean uh
flourishing by by Ala playing Queen to
B1 followed by Queen to to C1 that's I
mean that's some uh those are some fancy
Queen moves uh King to E8 now comes
Queen to H6 of course you go um for the
black king queen to A6 uh this queen to
A6 is a very deep idea uh not just that
it defends the F6 Pawn but also uh you
will see uh so Queen to H7 now comes
Pawn to E3 uh we have Queen to G8 with
check and now King to D7 Queen captures
an F7 with check King to see8 and now
and Knight captures an E3 and Wesley
this was the idea behind Queen to A6 now
plays Rook captures on E3 and his idea
is that if Pawn captures then he has
Queen to A1 with check and if King G2
then Queen captures and B2 check will
pick up the bishop as well and okay
objectively the end game is still
winning for alza he has the outside past
AG Pawn uh but you know it's it's a
queen and ponent game maybe you can
still force your opponent to blunder at
least a little bit but ala of course did
not fall for this he played Queen to G8
with check now regardless of where you
place the king queen captures on D5 will
come with check so uh King to B7 was
played Queen captures on D5 with check
Pawn to C6 and now Queen to D7 with
check King to B8 we have F captures on
E3 now it's perfectly fine as both the
queen and the bishop control the D1
Square Wesley did give up one check but
now Bishop to D1 the queen defends it
and of course there is no more way to
play this you could capture the pawn but
then Queen captures on C6 and you're
just down a full piece there's no way to
play this uh so yeah very nicely done by
Ala the defeating Wesley so like this
and also Al Magnus and defeating Fabiano
corana that means that alza will face
Magnus Carlson in the finals and uh well
as usual it will be a true battle for
the future now uh I also have the
standings here so uh sorry about that no
idea why this happened oh yeah I have an
idea why this happened uh there you have
it those are the uh the results of day
two so Magnus defeated Fabiano with a
score of two and a half to one and a
half so he started by winning the first
two games and the third game was won by
Fabby but the fourth game was a draw
that means that Magnus wins 2 and a half
to one and a half and the Wesley so same
result against ala only it resulted by
three draws and then alza lost the
fourth game this is the fourth game that
we've just shown so two and a half to
one and a half both of them and now they
will face each other to see who will be
the winner of the winner section of the
uh of the Ulus bar generation cup uh so
yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it both of them uh very nicely
done I mean that weird weird move from
Magnus where you he basically forces
Fabby to sacrifice a pawn into a better
position but Fabi I guess he didn't know
about the position and he just defended
opponent it was enough for Magnus to
completely take over the game and alza
just you know found two two two
brilliant tactics here after Knight
captures on D5 he immediately spots
Bishop captures on H6 which is already
unpleasant but then after you see this
position with G captures uh on F6 and
Ala plays Queen to B1 I mean your your I
mean you I'm pretty sure Wesley was just
uh disgusted with himself when he saw
Queen to be one uh so I hope you enjoyed
both of the games I I I truly enjoy them
and I'm very happy to show you what will
happen in the finals I would like to
thank gersy chess festival.org Dogg
India Moon India is the best Crazy Dave
and crazier Dave for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day